welcome to Paulina garden there are many
benefits of raised bed gardening a
raised bed that is about 1.5 to 2 feet
tall will be ideal for people with back
pain because they don't have to bend as
much while growing in a raised bed you
will spend less time pulling weeds out
gardening in raised beds prevents soil
compaction because you won't be working
on the soil and it provides good
drainage for all these reasons raised
beds are great for growing vegetables
and flowers in a small backyard garden
you can build raised beds using many
materials such as wood concrete metal or
even plastic based on your budget and
preference here is an example of a
raised bed built in 2015 using cinder
blocks or concrete blocks the advantage
of cinder blocks is that you can just
place them on the ground and quickly
build a raised bed and they last longer
than wood however because they are not
held together by anything gravity and
weight of the soil can push down on them
and create gaps between the blocks
especially in a garden area that slopes
just like mine this requires some
realignment to close the gaps every
season this raised bed is made up of two
layers of cinder blocks and this gives
me a good working height so I don't have
to bend a lot the next bed I have in my
backyard was built in 2016 using
untreated lumber bought from hardware
store it is not very high but it still
helps in controlling weeds what you see
here is a 2 feet tall keyhole shaped
raised bed under
construction I built this in 2017 and it
was also built using untreated lumber
bought from hardware store I started off
this raised bed by clearing the ground
of grass and weeds and then I leveled
the ground
place the first level of lumber and
joined them together using galvanized
screws I then placed some hardware cloth
or wire mesh on the ground on top of the
wire mesh I placed some cardboard
because it was going to be a two feet
tall structure I filled it up to a good
height with layer of twigs and garden
waste on top of the cardboard I then
topped off the raised bed by adding
compost première sphagnum peat moss
perlite and azomite rock dust and mixing
them well after about a year of growing
vegetables the level of soil went down
by four to six inches so I have topped
it off again as you can see here the
other thing I have done on this bed is
added irrigation drip irrigation as you
can see here the one thing that was
common in the three raised beds you saw
till now was that I had to spend money
to buy the materials required for
constructing these raised beds it does
not always have to be that way this year
that is in the year 2018 I am
constructing a raised bed with some wood
logs that are lying around in my
backyard these wood logs were delivered
last year by chip drop along with the
wood chips that you can see here and I'm
going to use these logs to construct a
raised bed the location for this raised
bed is at the north end of the garden by
the fence not an ideal location for
growing sun-loving vegetables but I can
try to grow vegetable
or plants that love partial shade or the
plants that can climb up the fence and
reach out for additional light I cleared
the ground of grass and weed seeds and
loosened the clay soil like you see here
there after I removed the soil from this
location and placed a hardware cloth on
the ground
this helps to discourage critters from
making burrows and reaching the raised
bed from underneath the ground had a
slope but I did not level it I'm just
going to place the wood logs along the
slope in a rectangle shape and form the
raised bed structure this is how it
looks like after the wood logs are
placed next I am going to fill this
raised bed with different materials to
form the growing medium I placed a layer
of cardboard on top of the hardware
cloth as it helps to block sunlight and
prevent the growth of any grass or weed
roots or weed seeds that may still exist
on the ground I placed a layer of
vegetable scraps from a kitchen on top
of the cardboard I reuse the clay soil
removed from this location earlier to
cover these vegetable scraps eventually
the vegetable scraps will decompose and
provide nutrition to the plant roots the
other ingredients used to fill this
raised bed
we're mushroom compost organic planting
soil from Costco course premium grade
perlite to provide better drainage in
the soil
Magnum peat moss as it helps to loosen
the soil and retain moisture and as a
mite rock dust used to replenish trace
minerals after adding all the items
shown earlier into the raised bed I used
a pitchfork
to mix them well that is how I consider
a raised bed using wood logs already
available in my backyard it got dark by
the time I completed this raised bed and
I apologize for the lower visibility
towards the end of this video recently a
friend of mine had requested me to
upload a video on raised bed I hope this
video is helpful for that friend and
also for all the viewers of Parana
garden channel if you like this video on
raised bed please hit the like button
also subscribe to piranhas garden
channel to get notified of video uploads
in the upcoming growing season thank you
for stopping by
enjoy gardening
[Music]